so when I started the home charlie
series initially I did it because I just
hit 25,000 subscribers on YouTube yay
and I thought that to celebrate I would
do 25 user submitted challenges so far
I've managed to do 24 of the challenges
that I said I do which means that this
today is the final challenge Charlie not
really I'll still probably do some more
but it's a special one than the less the
challenge that I've chosen submitted by
illustrious Tamara is therefore a fairly
special one it's to get covered in honey
and feathers which my friends Dan and
kind have agreed to do to me just before
we get to that though coincidentally
this year also happens to be the 25th
anniversary of way for it Red Nose Day
and so given the serendipity of the
situation 25 and 25 I figured I would
use this opportunity to attempt to raise
some money for charity as well and so if
you'd like to support me and doing this
silly challenge thingy you can't do by
going to Red Nose Day com forward slash
Charlie McDonnell and thank you now it's
time for me to humiliate myself for your
enjoyment so let's do that shall we yay
what am i doing with my life okay I'm
doing a circle
oh wow Oh God we doing the legs yeah do
the legs whoa
all right so course ah we're trying to
be gentle I appreciated hi Charlie
oh hello hi right you look great
thank you cool oh god oh and also post
challenge Charlie here that man who just
walked in that's Tim Minchin my favorite
musical comedian who never told me he
was shown up Mac story you may remember
Tim from when I got involved in Red Nose
Day a couple of years ago and attempted
to record a song with him but failed
miserably because I forgot to turn the
microphone on which is still something I
feel bad about apparently and I did
asked him to come along to the challenge
because you did I thought it would be a
good opportunity for him to get his own
back on me but he told me that he
couldn't come the liar anyway let's keep
going
oh so rotten oh okay ah it's good to see
ya
oh-oh-oh careful can you paint us now
thanks for coming
pleasure good missed another world this
very yummy I'd encourage you to have a
taste I'm ready okay do you want to grab
some feathers have you ready
I'll do the penis again and the penis
specialist I think I swallowed a feather
I imagine so my con that's what we
should have always done Charlie's a
visual gag I don't know I can good that
doesn't solve poverty now you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool I found that one of
the more gratifying moments in my life
and career both because for altruistic
reasons because I'm a giving person I
love to give and also because I owe
Charlie some punishment for being a
nincompoop and I really feel like I
killed two chickens with one stone give
money seriously you should give money
for this this is the best thing anyone's
ever done for anything thank you very
much